und jetzt mal zu einem thema über das
sich die deutschen viel zu selten auf
regen flüchtlinge die banken
entschuldigung
franken ja und zwar nicht weil die
deutsche bank endlich einen chef
gefunden hat der zu ihrem image passt
glückwunsch übrigens dazu wir müssen
über die hsh nordbank reden kennen sie
noch gehört der laden hamburg und
schleswig holstein wird aber jetzt
gerade fertigt an einen amerikanischen
hedgefonds die nordländer kriegen von
den heuschrecken zwar eine milliarde
euro müssen den aber im gegenzug rund
zehn milliarden an garantien für faule
kredite geben das heißt der steuerzahler
macht auf jeden fall 9 milliarden minus
segnen die landesparlamente oben gerade
ab dieses geschäft dazu daniel günther
der kindliche kaiser aus kiel
es ist noch nicht der letzte schritt
aber es ist ein großer schritt zu einem
schlussstrich unter den ausflug unserer
länder in die geschäftsbanken welt
ausflug allein die schleswig-holsteiner
kostet der ausflug ins finanzielle
phantasialand mindestens fünf milliarden
nur die ein bundesland mit einem
jahreshaushalt von insgesamt 12
milliarden grunde kannst du den ganzen
schafstall da oben dicht machen aber
komplett jetzt mal ehrlich die hsh eine
landesbank also im grunde eine bessere
sparkasse wollte vor 15 jahren unbedingt
ein globaler player werden
weltmarktführer bei schiffs krediten und
die wurden rausgehauen als gäb's kein
morgen
ich würde mit ihnen gemeinsam ein großes
fest feiern wollen wenn wir nicht in der
vergangenheit diese kredite gegeben
hätten ja ich bin darüber sehr betrübt
war und runzelt die stirn
ich bin geradezu verstimmt und
ungehalten meine damen und herren
wenn ich gefühl hätte ich würde heute
die eu kommission in brüssel hat schon
2011 gesagt diese bank ist nicht
lebensfähig besser abwickeln
trotzdem haben hamburg und schleswig
holstein weiter jahrelang geld rein
geballert die haben den rädern geradezu
schiffskredite aufgedrängt für schiffe
die keiner braucht die original bilder
von damals ist ready nicht
schiffskredite hsv junge doppelt 200
millionen für tolles container stift
oder weiß jemals kampf noch reicht hat
eine klink noch fünf brando drauflos
bekloppt sein und wie bekloppt
er klopft kann man nur warnen
ich sage es nochmal abwickeln wer wohl
die lösung gewesen dann trifft es
nämlich die anleger und nicht den
steuerzahler bei der west lb hat das zum
beispiel super funktioniert aber dann
müsste man als politiker natürlich
zugeben dass man jahrelang scheiße
gebaut hat hier der olaf scholz zum
beispiel der hatte doch als hamburger
bürgermeister jahrelang die aufsicht wir
sehen keine fehler war und dann musst du
wirklich zum august erstmals oft ja
das geht doch nicht
was er selber lachen
dieser mann ist jetzt übrigens unser
bundesfinanzminister
die kollegen von panorama habe neulich
noch mal bei ihm nachgehakt wir haben
bei seinem neuen haus angefragt antwort
die hsh sei ländersache
herr scholz sei nicht mehr zuständig
leider leider nicht mehr zuständig wir
wissen auch gar nicht wo der jetzt wo
und
wieder einer von diesen mietnomaden die
einfach weiterziehen es ist eigentlich
gar nicht zu glauben dass sich der
bürger gar nicht mehr so richtig
aufregen kann über so was so abgestumpft
sind wir schon in sachen banken